it seems not even Nintendo can keep its
hands out of the dlc pot I'm Tony this
is a game spot news update and to keep
up with all the new with Zelda content
be sure to subscribe it's true breath of
the wild will have a season pass which
gives you a bonus on launch day and two
expansion packs the launch day bonus
adds special treasure chests with quote
useful items and some exclusive outfits
for link the first DLC pack drops this
summer and it'll contain a new cave of
trials challenge a hard mode and a
special feature for the in-game map the
second pack coming this holiday adds a
new dungeon a new story and quote
additional challenges the season pass
will cost you twenty bucks on switch or
Wii U and the DLC packs will not be sold
individually breath of the wild launches
alongside the switch on March third if
you want some open world combat in the
meantime you can check out 13 minutes of
near automata gameplay over on gamespot
and for all the latest on zelda you're
already in the right place
you